[Música]
en eeuu la corte suprema anuló la
histórica sentencia conocida como roe
versus weight que desde 1973 garantizaba
el derecho al aborto en el país tras el
fallo del presidente joe biden criticó
la sentencia asegurando que se trata de
un trágico error del tribunal desde el
mismo viernes 24 de junio cuando entró
en vigencia esta norma varios estados ya
introdujeron prohibiciones en el mapa
que vamos a ver está entonces en rojo
los estados donde fue penalizado
inmediatamente o entrará en vigor en los
próximos 30 días como texas arkansas y
missouri en naranja están los estados
que probablemente lo van a prohibir como
arizona wisconsin o florida y en verde
los que toman las medidas para
protegerlo como california nevada alaska
hawai nueva york maryland y en gris los
que no son claros al respecto unas 36
millones de mujeres en edad reproductiva
se verán privadas de este derecho al
aborto saludamos entonces a nuestra
segunda invitada del día ella es mayra
rodríguez ex directora de planes fernet
además hace parte de la organización
pro-vida latam gracias mayra por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 como reciben ustedes este del
tribunal supremo que pasará además con
los derechos reproductivos de las
mujeres y personas gestantes que
quisieran interrumpir su embarazo
bueno primero que nada esta fue una
perfecta decisión de la corte suprema-
recordemos que lo único que yo están
diciendo es que el derecho al aborto no
existe no es un derecho constitucional y
eso es lo que esperábamos que sucediera
cuando robert sus wake se dio en el 73
se puso como un derecho constitucional
no existe el derecho al aborto como ex
empleada de la industria del aborto te
puedo decir que no existe aborto seguro
yo denuncié a plan para anholt por sus
malas praxis escuchaba en hace unos
segundos las cifras que nos estaban
dando y quiero que sepas que el aborto
legal en eeuu se hace a través del
raspado del útero entonces no existe
diferencia entre un aborto clandestino y
un aborto de chupa rampante hola y pp
efe conocida a nivel mundial entonces
esto es algo positivo para las mujeres
porque en los estados como en arizona
dónde yo radico se están implementando
normas para ayudar a proteger a estas
mujeres mejor que lo que la industria el
aborto les ofrecía también por ejemplo
en estados como texas hemos visto un
incremento en 60% del uso de
anticonceptivos y una disminución de
embarazos inesperados que eso es lo que
todos queremos todos queremos a las
mujeres saludables fuertes que estén
entregadas y que para nosotros esto es
algo positivo especialmente viviendo de
la industria del aborto habiendo
trabajado para ellos se puede decir que
este es un movimiento positivo para las
mujeres mayra también las personas que
defienden el derecho al aborto
consideran que lo que está mediando es
federal no va no va a disminuir los
abortos sino que más bien lo que hace es
que las personas restantes no puedan
tener una interrupción del embarazo
segura y por lo que su vida y salud está
en riesgo que dice usted al respecto
cuál es su posición
bueno como te decía hace rato habiendo
trabajado en la industria de la corte te
puedo decir que no existe a puerto
seguro una vez más ciones denuncié a
plan para ángeles por la mala praxis de
los abortos entonces esto es algo que la
gente tiene más de información cuando es
trabajo en la industria labor de
transcont activa en diferencia entre el
aborto para el destino y el aborto
realizado en una clínica con licencia no
existe entonces realmente y las mujeres
no van a ser encarceladas esto es falso
no es verdad que van a ser encarcelar si
fueron violadas y buscan un aborto
quiero que sepan que esas tres causales
lamentablemente siguen siendo protegidas
aún en los estados con restricciones el
aborto sigue siendo ilegal por motivos
de salvarle la vida a la madre el aborto
sigue siendo legal en caso de un incesto
violación eso no se ha quitado y hay una
mala información entonces
no se trata de que es simplemente no es
un derecho no es que una mujer como
sucede abrir de nueva york y california
a las 38 semanas de gestación puede
decir ya no quiero tener a mi bebé voy a
aborto por sin ninguna razón de salud
sin ningún motivo alguno más que
simplemente un ya no quiero ser madre
claro ellas también les dicen digamos en
las consignas que hacen pues rechazando
esta medida es mi cuerpo mi decisión
porque no dejarlas a ellas a pues estar
en el pleno derecho de sus derechos
individuales como mujeres y tomar la
decisión sobre su cuerpo
por la decisión a pueden tomar
perfectamente sobre su cuerpo antes de
quedar embarazadas existen muchísimos
métodos en que si prestamos existen
muchísimos métodos anticonceptivos para
prevenir un embarazo inesperado es ahí
es donde tienes la autonomía sobre su
cuerpo al decidir no quedar embarazadas
como trabajadora una vez más de plan
prime web donde le dedique 16 años para
dar servicios preventivos que incluían
anticonceptivos existen muchísimos
métodos las mujeres han sido engañadas
por la industria del aborto como que
este es el mejor método anticonceptivo
en sus vidas las cuales se está dañando
yo tengo el testimonio de varias mujeres
que fueron dañadas en plan power y que
hoy no podrían ser madres por los daños
ocasionados por un aborto así que el
aborto no está solucionando el problema
del embarazo inesperado al contrario
está simplemente siendo multimillonaria
a una multinacional como life pp ya
basta de cue system y haciéndose ricos
con nuestro cuerpo
mayra cree usted que las mujeres van a
estas clínicas para digamos entrar una
interrupción del embarazo o una como
médico como método anticonceptivo
sí claro yo tuve una paciente que tuvo
26 abortos pero decayeron mega la norma
es un general
y creo yo que la mayoría de las mujeres
cree que es muy fácil ir a abortar y que
entonces no importa que no hayan tomatti
coactivos cuidados eo prevendió hablemos
ahora de los hombres que creen que no
necesitan cuidarse no necesitan usar
condones no necesitan no tener una vida
de promiscuidad porque al final de
cuentas le dan unos cuantos cientos de
dólares de esa mujer y la mandan a
abortar recordemos que el aborto a quien
más se está beneficiando es al hombre
irresponsable que podría prevenir esos
embarazos otras comunidades también
hablando de los derechos civiles mayra y
como la comunidad lgtb por ejemplo tm en
que la ley de que los ampara bajo el
matrimonio igualitario pues ese sea un
retroceso teniendo en cuenta que pues
ahora en eeuu tenemos una corte suprema
de justicia mayoría conservadora que le
diría a las personas lo mejor que temen
porque sus derechos civiles pues sean
digamos un retroceso como algunos han
llamado
ya que la misma industria que ha
engañado a las mujeres diciéndoles que
el aborto es necesario para ellas está
engañando a la comunidad del gp no es
verdad que el aporte suprema esté
trabajando en eso y tampoco es eeuu va a
permitir que le quiten los derechos vaya
todos queremos que todo ser humano tenga
derechos los derechos básicos y el
primer derecho es el de la vida entonces
pensando en la comunidad del egb t-cue
tienen que entender que para tener
derechos necesitan que los dejemos de
hacer
que le dice a las mujeres que quisieran
abortar por alguna u otra razón bien sea
también por estas tres causales que fue
incesto que fue producto de una
violación o que en la vida de las
mujeres ese corre peligro
como te digo es lamentablemente para mí
porque digo ya no existen razones
suficientes para el aborto a esta época
de la ciencia tan avanzada pero la mujer
sigue pudiendo tener aborto por caso de
enfermedad o si ella es tu vida está en
peligro el aborto seguirá siendo legal
en los estados aún con restricciones
ahora una mujer por violación yo en mi
caso personal y hablando con muchas
personas que han dado su testimonio el
aborto no es la mejor solución para
ellas pero una vez más sigue siendo
legal en la mayor parte de eeuu entonces
que primeros informes y que no es verdad
que las van a mandar a la cárcel que no
es verdad que es un retroceso para ellas
y que no es verdad que serán perseguidas
ninguna mujer va a ir a la cárcel